what are you still doing you you to
those sons of [ __ ] they took all my
money
they demonetised all my videos as you
can see by this background I'm living in
there I'm living in the slums I'm eating
Edgar's dog food that's right I I made
some bad investments okay I did I I
thought it was gonna work out who knew
rats couldn't live underneath water okay
maybe I maybe I should have seen that
one coming
god dammit why do I invest all my money
in the rat under water rats nah leprosy
I have leprosy now I'm gonna have to get
a new job don't you understand the
serious and see of the situation why
aren't you looking at me huh no no I am
not sunk in that low yet I'm gonna have
to find another job what job am i
qualified what talents do I have as a
youtuber as a joke because the youtubers
doesn't have talent Photoshop Photoshop
that's right
Aynsley Photoshop let's see on Twitter
what people want made of Photoshop
daddio 5 as a happy wholesome American
family and that's just straight-up
impossible
don't be ridiculous Danville cinnamon
toast can the future of YouTube right
there zoom in on the nipple
[Music]
the real future of YouTube you just go
to the trending tab and look whatever
cancer is on that [ __ ]
we got Roman Atwood Vox hi Justine and
what's up mom's Photoshop Wall Street
Journal into a good publication okay
that should be easy enough I accept your
challenge all right we have the Wall
Street Journal logo here and let's let's
make some fine-tuning adjustments change
the letters a little bit we rearrange
essentially just rearrange what we're
looking at here oh wow
it's it's starting to look like
something could it be a good publication
my god
let's add some coloring beautiful Dolan
that will be fede bucks okay you can
PayPal me who's chaos says [ __ ] me up
well this has already been photoshopped
okay you clearly use some [ __ ] filter
to smooth out his skin what are you
[ __ ] alright what can we do with this
I don't [ __ ] know I'm gonna be honest
here you look like [ __ ] I'm sorry you
don't look great but there there is a
solution okay I have a problem with the
fact that you're trying to steal my hair
and but I will say you have a huge
[ __ ] nose and you know represent as a
fellow member of the big-ass nose
community I appreciate you and I want to
accentuate your best features why I
can't submit by just lifting them up
just a tiny bit we don't want you to
look weird or bad or anything so let's
just do that
so let's subscribe that beautiful nose
and let's get rid of you wow that is
knowledge
Wow can you tell I'm good at Photoshop
oh my god it looks so real can't you
tell by the pixels yep I'm definitely
not regretting spending time on this one
I definitely think this was worth the
effort make him happy who cries on
camera what a goddamn loser I can't
allow that to happen I will do it for
free this should be easy
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] it up I [ __ ] it up
god damn it I'm not cut out for this
Jasmine G make me into a dodge please
notice me senpai it's my dream to be in
one of your vids well your wish is my
command as long as you pay pal I have a
feeling she's gonna regret this I just
found the perfect dodge the perfect I
mean already I can't tell the difference
alright let's start with the eyes make
it make it nice and simple to be honest
already you look ten times better Felix
the plastic surgeon here to fulfill all
your needs moving on to the nose that
looks great
I love my lime thank you for asking yes
I think we're getting somewhere
next time it'd be really great if you
could send me a like a little lower rest
photo bad that would be really helpful
thank you it looks like we're gonna have
to give you a complete new set of teeth
yes yes now just the ears I don't see
your ear so I'm just gonna have to guess
actually never mind there's a little ear
tip that's all we got to work with
that's all we were doing yeah yes proper
dog ears Wow look at that and you're
already wearing a necklace so there
there you go Oh oh my god Jesus Christ
let's have a little look-see before
after my god you look great honey
that'll be 50 bucks thank you oh my god
if this continues I might be able to
support myself make me into a helicopter
you know what I felt privileged to help
you in your transition into an Apache
helicopter you're so brave let's take
your sorry don't mean to be rude but you
have weird-ass fingers disgusting but
they will make you fly [ __ ] like did
you have to cover up your whole goddamn
face Wow so brave okay what a great
goddamn [ __ ] dumb oh my god okay
another satisfied customer
Wow it feels great that I can make
people feel good can you give me big
muscular arms a poor soul in pain in
need he doesn't have any arms it will be
my honor my privilege and my duty you
know some people say that using
Photoshop generated arms it's unethical
dangerous can cause life
life-threatening disease no I say no
there's nothing wrong with it
there's nothing wrong with having arms
and if you have a problem with having
arms you've got a problem with me cuz I
have arms what the [ __ ] am I talking
about dude you're gonna look so swole
who needs a workout when you look this
good when you look this good boy damn
dog you gonna [ __ ] them hoes up hit man
you look [ __ ] hell attack holy [ __ ]
no you look amazing another satisfied
customer thank you
give Gerard his eyebrows back what
happened to Gerard's eyebrows you know
what not Mike not none of my best ngata
my Beza
I have always wondered I know you
thinking you've thought the same thing
I've always wondered what would it be
like to have okay let's say that let's
say it on three one two caterpillar
eyebrows yes on point held high five
caterpillar eyebrows it's the new
hippest trend that a lot of people don't
know about I was a fan of caterpillar
before caterpillars were cool okay
alright alright caterpillars it's my
thing
it's what I define my identity around
caterpillars I've been thinking about
this caterpillar thing for a long time
and I want you to know Gerard if you
actually want me to set you up with some
caterpillar eyebrows I can give you
discount just cuz I really like your
music would you like some candy Peter a
bee get down there and come now you get
two caterpillar for free you get one
Calvin Frank that's Frank you get to
print a caterpillar free wow he looks
good it looks really good it feels
rewarding it's Edgar's turn to be in the
middle Jesus guys charile it was pretty
pie come on Wallace read you want Brodie
pie I swear I can tell you everything
about fix this
okay no problem you're welcome that'll
be another 50 here's a classic example
of how the [ __ ] am I supposed to do that
turn me into this pug okay well you're
covering your whole guy do you have
glasses and a [ __ ] mug in your face
how am I supposed to do that
now just because you'd made such a dumb
suggestion I'm gonna turn this cup into
the bug look what an amazing time that
part that mug has what if the [ __ ] am i
doing god dammit
the [ __ ] on monetization man I don't
know what to do I don't know what to do
but now I know thanks to you guys and my
amazing talent we can work this out
together
appreciate you and as always a little
high came in without one